so this is my lineup right now Magic's
the one Kobe at the two Kawhi defensive
specialist it's a three young LeBron at
the four cap at the five he's super
solid
[Music]
my advice to anybody starting out
playing my team for the first time is
just go to the market check everything
out kind of get like a inventory of who
is out there Steph Curry's always good
great shooter this card right here is
one guy I always try to go after magic
super fast finishes well around the
basket Hakeem one of my favorite bigs in
all of my team I love the aspect of you
know combining the old and the new if
you know your basketball if you know
history of the game you can use a lot of
these players to your advantage things
like the coaches playbooks shoes those
all make a difference
but one thing I like to do before I
start sometimes I go into a domination
just like an easy game just to get the
feel for the players get the feel the
shots their mechanics it'll get you
warmed up I've been playing 2K since 2K7
2K7 was the first 2K that made me fall
in love with it but I'm in a lifelong
fan of this I feel like since high
school they make it exciting to play
they make it challenging there he is
seeing myself in 2K for the first time
was kind of surreal because up until the
point I got drafted I was creating my
own player every single year this is
before you know you can just upload your
your Facebook scan and and call it good
so for me it was special man always
check your unopened packs you always
need to go and make sure that there's
nothing left and open oh speaking of
Game Changers so I just got Vince
Carteret shooting guard anything over 91
92 throw them onto the team immediately
all right time for a triple threat game
nope King Garden oh we're about to
dominate this game give it a half man
half amazing
oh that's why people love 2K man
the dunks the threes the step backs
game time
yeah I've been playing this for a couple
months now so my team is a little more
personalized the way I like to play
Let's open up a pack real quick what did
I just get I got a T-Mac car I love that
there he is sometimes when I get really
good cards like this I'll send this one
to my auction my team right now is
pretty good but at the same time I'm
always on the look for better players
ooh they got a cat here we go I can
either bid
or I can just buy it outright
[Music]
clutch is great it's one quarter four
pointers are allowed and the shot clock
is cut to 14. dunk him no shot clock
come on brownie there's a defense bro
streaming on game days for me is fun
kind of relaxing it's almost like The
Scouting Report sometimes let's go cap
oh get dunked on I've always admired the
dunk contest to actually participate and
then go out there and win it definitely
you know one of the better moments of my
career dunks are are definitely one of
my favorite aspects of this game and
each year they get better and better
they just keep you know up in the ante
every year
there we go code would you say you're
the best UK player in the league until
somebody proves me you know prove me
wrong I'm the best player four pointer
oh